vous savez que les stars c'est une
information complètement insolite josé
garcia tout le monde connaît les égards
et s'est lancé dans le commerce avec sa
propre marque de rose et ce qui est
encore plus fou c'est que le nom qu'il a
donné opposée il va s'appeler josé
garcia
et la drôle
mais si c'est sympa en plus ça oui bah
oui évidemment l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé et autres
produits dérivés voilà c'est tout
produit
vous connaissez les produits dérivés des
stars parce que là moi j'en ai trouvé
tout à l'heure quand on m'a donné ce
thème doit les trouver est-ce que vous
en connaissez vous bah oui il ya le bain
d huile
nomades de paul newman carole il y avait
elle maquille existe
y adapter qu'il a de george clooney et
george hill a fait plus d'un milliard de
dollars avec l'aca avec la boîte une
heure c'est pas très insolite le vin de
brad pitt
bouquet
jeunesse qui vient de sortir une tequila
alors nous on n'a trouvé mieux regarder
la vie qui sent le vagin ah bon
dans l'odeur deuxième adjoint alors si
vous voulez sentir je suis désolé de
dire ça comme ça c'est moi qui sais que
ça peut choquer joue à l'étape confusion
de moi c'est qu'il faut débourser 60 3
euros pour que flotte l'odeur intimes de
la star de rotonde salon même si on peut
pas laisser la bougie allumée plus de
deux heures a explosé
[Rires]
produire et nous on fait n'importe quoi
c'est avec carphone avec ça s'appelle
comme
ça vous dit la bougie ou non merci ça
ira merci bien sûr personnes par an et
non j'ai pas besoin de ça la maison j'ai
mon odeur déjà
j'aurais pas dû poser la question
élaboré en forme de fès de kim
kardashian va la connaissez l'odeur
c'est regarder c'est joli non oui c'est
vrai c'est directement inspirée de son
boule
jolie votre visage au livret a mais
c'est rigolo signification
c'était des bourses à la signification
est beau
quand même quoi bon regarder ses fesses
c'est pas la chatte de gwyneth paltrow
connu pour sa voix
contre 11 et changer de sujet la lutte a
été très dur j'ai en tout cas ses fesses
de carnation ses 83 euros il est
conseillé de monter pas plus de trois
personnes quand même chose ces faits se
voit là et s'est produit à votre nom
vous ce serait quoi par exemple gilles à
moi un mégaphone avec ma voix hurlant
dans les rues
moi j'ai déjà travaillé sur le projet et
ça va bientôt sortir je vous annonce en
exclusivité pour vous d'un michael we
may lancé le premier wonderbra pour rob
et qui permet en fait de bien dessiné le
chignon pectoral c'est bien c'est à 13
[Applaudissements]
bonne idée mais moi je pensais vous
savez les petits chaussons avec les
têtes d'animaux là oui on a fait avec
mérite ma tête c'est à dire être sympa
non vous les défenses sakhaline c'est
mignon de chansons quoi - c'est mignon
d'accord guillaume une marque de
vêtements bien sûr bah oui bien sûr ses
couleurs à des défauts ni
ses fringues mais c'est d'être ou pas
c'est un film d'une famille que ça coûte
très cher mais c'est plus cher
exactement et puis l'on braque c'est un
truc qui la colère en arrivant genre
pour commettre ça fait partie ça fait
partie du coup ça fait partie mais elle
est très jolie delphine vous feriez quoi
moi une gamme de soins cosmétiques
naturels éthique et on est en train de
travailler dessus effectivement ça va
décrocher mieux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
que lui il est très sensible à son
épiderme sociales et autres donc du coup
ces crèmes pourront vraiment dû servir
toile dernier soit guillaume ça date de
quand soins du visage et d'une semaine
voilà je vous ai proposé de venir
d'ailleurs oui maman passé ensemble
jamais fait ça sympa
sophie vous feriez quoi vous mais je me
suis peut-être un costard tu vas se
serait ce serait un des costumes pour
hommes très bien taillés avec des pièces
d'art derrière tu vas des photos d'art
c'est pas mal an les stars
[Rires]
elle a demandé à une équipe marketing de
bosser sur vos profils mais tous mes
potes là voilà voilà ce qu'ils ont
proposé regarder le castel dictionnaire
c'est un dictionnaire les justes de
l'aide
vous faites vous fait un très bon début
d'émission mal
allez vous le dire
gilles verveine c'est un spray nasal
jean-michel fruits de mer c'est un
mollusque after
une sophie low cost c'est une réplique
de sotie corps avec ils n'étaient que
les six à sept et patti
l'actionnaire vous a pas oubliés fiona
saint pensionnat avec 1500 lits pour
héberger tous les ex des chiots da dont
l'état ainsi qu'au niveau de mes enfants
c'était en conséquence vous a pas oublié
la dell swing b spieser c'est une
rappeuse alsacienne kaïno barbichette
dire on vous a pas oubliés non plus avec
bien les auteurs comme ils sont là jean
tondeuse
à cheveux qui te permet de faire des
contours de merde
visa n'est pas oubliée là isabelle
morini bosc et une pelle pour un lot
logue qui permet d'aider terrain des
dinosaures et autres fossiles eh ben
elle a côtoyé pendant son adolescence
mais d'ailleurs je vais participer au
financement de la résurrection des
mammouths avec c'est un vrai projet il
me dit que c'est tout à fait pour moi ça
n'a pas trouvé les bottes
[Rires]
mais vous avez participé vraiment
maintenant pc et clc la souche et d
ennemi pour nos moutons
son départ est vraiment vraiment à
boules quiès titah bouchons d'oreilles
qui te permet d'entendre les coups de
gueule de raymond avec sade à 45 5
décibels en moins
jean pièces des auteurs n'ont pas oublié
alors moi c'est la lampe bernard et une
lampe à uv qui te fait un teint hâlé 365
jours par an j'y vivais dans un rien
[Applaudissements]